it is time for drew's news your daily
bowl of fresh good news pasta with that
perfect al dente chew
[Laughter]
and with me at the desk
is my main news noodle ross math that's
right hi everybody hi
oh i know you're excited about this week
i know it's pasta week and we're
throwing a five-day all-out pasta party
to celebrate one of the best
i hear
we have a pasta proclamation from the
pasta queen herself
chef nadia katarina
hi everyone munoz it's me
matriarch of the macaroni family i am so
thrilled you're celebrating my favorite
food pasta i want you to enjoy all the
pastas in the pasta kingdom so today i'm
officially anointing you
pasta queen and pasta king of pasta week
you may now put on your crumbs
first of all thank you nadia now the
pasta queen is a very very beloved
woman on tick tock and she was kind
enough to do our show in the very
beginning we made pasta alimony which is
one of my very favorite pastas in the
world rossi i see that you have i'm not
kidding it's hard to talk because my
tongue and my mouth just want to be here
you have a different pasta in front of
you what pray tell are you eating i love
she asked me a question it's only so she
can eat her pasta you guys saw that
right like she really doesn't care i
know you care but like you're just
focused on that but so yours is a pasta
a la lamone right
so my favorite pasta is an untraditional
one it's gonna surprise some of you this
is cold pasta salad with like the
vegetables in it and like the mayo base
you know what i'm talking about i love
pasta salad brushing and it's sort of
sweet because of the relish and
tang girl
this is tang full that's exactly what
this is well first up in our in our news
today and stories is some noodle news
for almost a week it's about robert
pattinson oh you love robert pattinson
doesn't hello i don't know is there
someone here who doesn't like robert
pattinson speak now show yourself
well either i scared you or it is true
he is beloved by all in the cut reports
that the newest batman has his very own
pasta dream he wants to create the first
pasta you can hold in your hand and he
calls it pasta
cucino
he already has run experiments he sticks
together a lump of penne with layers of
sugar and cheese and coats it with corn
flakes and then microwaves it and he
says it should be served on a bun like a
hamburger it hasn't come together yet
but robert is serious he even met with
frozen food companies against the advice
of his management oh dear oh dear
i mean that's against nature don't you
think all that together coats it with
the cheese and then he microwaves it and
one of the things that i found out um
from digging into the details was that
he says all of
life's pleasure foods
burgers sandwiches tacos are all hand
friendly but pasta is not and it's time
for it to be
okay well uh
[Applause]
let me tell you
let me tell you how cruel nature is that
robert pattinson can look like robert
pattinson and eat that and i would walk
by smell it and look like this you are
saying unacceptable mother nature also
do you know what cocina cocina means
cushion cushion which is exactly what
you get if you eat what rubber bands did
makes you
but you can make me one rubber band i'll
try it anything that our paths does
works for me works for me too
[Music]